hello and welcome to this video playing
Masoud 13 v 1j and platon recently don't
remember what that was probably the same
opening scotch four nights
you ever get the mainline t5 now or
castles age six that cannot be good okay
the dead is just downright losing right
attacking the bishop and Bishop age six
yeah I just loses immediately
in the window size material at least g6
Bishop d6
well you can win quickly with the Scotch
for nights it is possible wow that was a
short game yeah here and this position
black should really go d5 you can play
rookie a door d6 50 fibers it's the most
logical move here put this in the center
and age h6 is just downright not working
just after you 5 you're in terrible
shape the night has no good square 95 we
saw in the game and something like that
you're just setting yourself up for
Bishop oops
whoo Bishop takes h6 sent hmm and 95
that's just that's just an immediate
disaster yeah he was afraid of Bishop g5
but it really is not a problem like in a
situation here I go 83 but this is the
traditional mainline can always play c6
lend more protection to the pawn and
it's not such a big deal of this and
they spend even lines like that here
black is completely okay you know it's
it's equal there's this kind of
structure
I made an inaccuracy really okay
Bishop age 7 is made next move Bishop f5
is made and in three moves
okay like what but what was inaccurate
okay short game that illustrates an
important point in this opening that you
have to put something in the center
the thing is M over here you can play d5
immediately here here you five is
premature here
yo in the e-file but after I Castle this
is a threat and therefore black has to
put d5 on the board or d6
rupee eight balls stopping e5
after d6 by the way Bishop g5 is a bit
annoying because then you can only get
rid of that pin with 86 mg 5 so if you
don't want to play d5 I would recommend
to go Lukey 8 which is a fully playable
move ok guys thanks a lot for watching